i'm going to be on the surreal life uh
seriously on vh1 uh starting in january
i think it's going to be there
they're bringing that back we brought it
back yeah so
they put us in this 30 000 square foot
house in mexico city a few months ago oh
you already filmed it you already filmed
it um and i'll say this
i was the nice person that everybody
liked and i got punched twice
so i have no idea what they're gonna
show because the producers kept having
to come in and be like this is not what
we wanted the show to be we wanted it to
be like fun and light not like the kind
of the old real life it was more train
wrecking they wanted to be more like
uh us just doing this really cool stuff
and uh
it was wow it was rough can you say who
the rest of the cast is
yeah i think it's come out um it's
dennis rodman amazing uh
uh tamar braxton
um she was she's like tony brown tony
braxton's sister but tamar which was a
host of like the talk or the
one of those uh she had her own reality
show
um she won celebrity big brother uh
manny mua the youtube yeah yeah makeup
artist who
to be honest if he wasn't there him and
kim coles kim coles was on living single
and in living color back in the 90s
you'd wreck you definitely would
yeah if if they weren't there
there would have been a homicide
us three we call ourselves s3 the sober
three because we're the only ones who
weren't
going crazy
but if they weren't there there's no way
we would have all made it through wow
so dennis rodman wasn't sober the whole
time
he's not part of the s3
he's the leader this is the s3
this kid august alcina he um
is a r b singer okay he's
i don't i don't wanna i i don't care if
he likes me or not he wasn't the
greatest person but maybe i shouldn't
say that but he was the one who like had
an affair with jada pickett smith yeah
and will like the will i feel like she's
had an affair with everybody yeah i mean
even me
i was 15.
um no uh
but yeah it was just it was an
interesting group
and i'm really curious to see what it
what they make it look like because you
sold me dude i'm gonna check it out it
wasn't it was gnarly wow
unbelievable and and uh presumably vh1
will will have some streaming platform
but that would be a paramount plus yeah
probably yeah yeah yeah
that's probably their motivation for for
doing it to draw more subscribers to
paramount plus
yeah
i'm glad i asked that dude no [ __ ] yeah
i don't it's weird because i don't know
what the show is going to be meaning
like you know because they even they
have cameras in the bathrooms they have
cameras
there's not a moment that's not filmed
and you go
i don't know how they can't show some of
this stuff but they're so i don't know
if like me being like oh it's going to
be crazy and they're like they cut all
the crazy out somehow i have no idea so
i don't know how much i want to talk
[ __ ] on people okay because there were
people i definitely headed in that house
wow but but for all we know you might
end up looking like a dick on the show
if they cut it right i can't see that
happening okay okay other than in the
last interview i i unleashed on
everybody because i was like i i don't
want to protect these people anymore
they don't deserve protecting wow
fascinating very juicy stuff dude do you
know when that comes out i think they're
saying sometime in january i'm not
entirely sure wow
[ __ ] fascinating dude
i've really really enjoyed talking to
you that's really cool it's been fun
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass
and a lot of it is flagrantly illegal so
it's adults only and if you live in any
of these states then you better go to
stevo.com and check out my tour schedule
hurry up and get your tickets too
because it's selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]